The second major kind of relationship that you use in
UML class model diagrams is generalization. Generalization is
also indicated by a solid line, but in this case the line ends with a triangle.
The class rectangle that's adjacent to the triangle is the superclass or
parent class. And the other class rectangle is the child class or subclass.
The semantic import of generalization is that
all instances of the subclass are also instances of the parent class. That is
there's a subset relationship. Let me warn you though that generalization is
not the same as inheritance in object oriented programming languages.
Inheritance is an implementation technique, generalization is a modeling,
approach. We'll see how that difference plays out later in the course.
In UML, generalization supports both multiple parent classes for
a given class and multiple child classes for a given parent class. Moreover,
you can specify discriminators. That is names of groups of subclasses.
So here's an example of the UML class model diagram in
which generalization is illustrated. We have a superclass called Vehicle.
Note that it's got four lines coming into it each with an open triangle so
it's got four sub-classes. Those sub-classes are wind powered vehicle,
motor-powered vehicle, land vehicle and water vehicle.
Notice also that we have two grandchild classes.
We have trucks and we have sailboats. So let's think for a minute
about trucks. Trucks are motor powered vehicles are motor powered vehicles but
they're also land vehicles, that is truck has two parent classes.
Similarly sailboat is a wind powered vehicle and a water vehicle so
its got two parent classes as well. With respect to the parent level.
We have two categories of sub-classes. We have a category related to
the power that moves the vehicle, it might be wind or
it might be motor. And we have a category having this labeled here as venue,
indicating where the vehicle does its moving. Is it on land or is it on water?
Also visible in this diagram are some properties in curly braces.
Those properties indicate properties of the sub-classes. If a parent class has
two child classes, and instances can belong to both of the child classes.
We want to use the overlapping property. If that
can't be the case that is if a given instance can only belong to one child,
we say that those particular sub-classes are disjoint,
their members belong to one of the child classes not the other and. But
by our definition of generalization, the instances do belong to the,
to the parent class. A second kind of constrained or
property we might want to express is whether or
not the set, of child classes covers all of the instances or not.
If that's the case we say, we would use the, property, complete, and
otherwise we would say incomplete. Why might a modeling situation be incomplete?
Well you might have some weird hybrid vehicle that doesn't belong to any of the.
The child classes, but nevertheless we want to have an instance that,
that recognizes it, or, or models it, say the Segway, for example.